what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch today from our friends of
our new rockstars
one division episode five their
breakdown
of the recently released footage trailer
and you know their theories easter eggs
predictions and whatnot they're the best
at this game
let's see what's in store
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division's mysteries are
starting to come into focus now that
episode 4
took us outside of west view and gave us
terrifying context from avengers end
game and avengers infinity war best cold
opens
promo footage four episode five dropped
in some huge clues for the
epic showdown ahead is disneyland
everything with these promos i don't
think so
only really the curious cats probing
into the visual details with rewatch
upon rewatch risk nearing that
precious truth and even then we usually
end up with more questions on our jimmy
woo new rockstars trolling boards
so let us break down everything we
learned about wanda mission from this
episode 5
sneak peek let's get started
we now have first person intel from
inside the west view anomaly okay these
are mostly visuals from the most recent
episode
here except now hayward is jumping on
this opportunity to have monica back so
that
you know how much he hates him inside
west view based on my theories about
this guy i'm sure he's real eager to be
the first one to interview monica now
this sword command center has this
awesome map table with the globe of the
sword logo rotating i like how the outer
layer this logo has eight stars
four on each side of a central bright
ninth star
i wonder if these could represent the
nine realms with midgard and
earth in the center across the
continents are some blinking text
i actually really like that idea if it
does represent uh all nine realms
because they got darcy lewis
in here it was reminding me of the first
thor movie when she showed up i don't
know having a little bit of linkage to
thor in that little easter egg
nuance would be pretty neat absolutely
one in the east mediterranean off the
southern coast of turkey
another that for a second looks like
it's around my hometown at jacksonville
florida
duval portal
oh if sword headquarters is based on
cape canaveral this could be showing
sword hq
duval on the screens behind them show
what looks like the 80s episode inside
west
view the family ties looking home set
actually dressed up as uh katie gibler
from full house i'm actually assuming we
will get some kind of meta nod to
olson's
sister's house what are we looking at
here is it an alternate reality
time travel it's a sitcom starring two
avengers
it's a working theory
again more stuff from past episodes
except this new shot that looks like it
is from the 80s episode intro
jean skirt vision calculator many have
noticed how consistently everyone in
westview appears to wear watches despite
the time dilation
jimmy wu does ask if time travel is
going on and he wrote same time and
space on the board
and with the strucker watch the clock
radio the clock and toaster commercial
time is important in fact out of sync
clocks
could be key to vision's awakening and
based on the
notes in episode how he is awakening
others in the town
and then the way the camera pushes in on
them
to be fair though clocks and watches
are common very common everywhere in
life
especially during the 50s and 60s i
think a lot of people would have
a lot of all time a lot of us have cell
phones with time
on them now but clocks and watches are
not exactly out of this
part it reminds me of the motion of that
shot in the full house opening remember
how it
rushes up on the tanners in that park in
san francisco probably fleeing aunt
becky hitting them up for bail money ooh
life moves fast out in the suburbs i
think something's wrong here
should we just take it from the top
now we know the 80 set will feature the
boys still as
babies and we see wanda in this outfit
later on that 80s set so if this is all
still the 80s these boys would be older
now
maybe aging too fast for the decades to
keep up now it's interesting that
breaks character in resets this way
should we just take it from the top
normally rwanda is the one to break
reality halt everything
edit these scenes in progress from
within so the fact that agnes is making
the call here might suggest that wanda's
ability to edit these moments does not
work on agnes kind of like that
magnus is another unaccounted for west
view component
that is beyond wanda's control put that
stork on the wall
of wanda's modern family or malcolm the
middle home it's glitching through
layers of construction but then vision
says this
what is outside of westfield you sound
pretty emotional things like rumen for
the truman show demanding to leave sea
haven what's on the outside
and then we see vision trying to push
out through that cmbr static
wall i'm thinking this could be right
after that nighttime footage of him
soaring up over westview from the
trailer
for the first time getting a sense of
this fictitious reality
right right yeah yeah
[Music]
cool
yeah i'm not sure what that's about it's
probably just a case of the mondays
am i right here once again the closing
shot of episode four was so much
happening at montana
looking out over that tv set directly at
us
but then this armored sword vehicle
carrying some kind of cargo
rams the west view border wall as it is
lit up red now we have seen it glow this
threatening color in other shots i feel
like this is what westview looks like
when wanda feels threatened
based on the windows of that vehicle
this looks like the vehicle that the
pilot is in not the helicopter
right other cockpit interior shot that
we've seen now this vehicle is numbered
9219r
i did check to see if there's any
significant 1992 vision scarlet witch
comic or just maybe not
every number on the show means something
i love this shot i love that shot of it
ramming in it just feels like
america yeah i know get in there
we could do this metal we got bombs
let's do it
i don't think that's how it's gonna play
but it just feels that way initially
when you see this
like just get in there and blow it up
hit it really hard a much clearer
version of another shot that we've seen
before the static wall as some
silhouette comes through it you can
actually see their legs as it's coming
through
vision that's off it seems like we don't
think this is vision as we saw on the
other shot of him leaving west view
based on the
coat and the hair it actually looks more
like wanda oh
cam when you outline that [ __ ] yeah to
the left of this figure
definitely like they are carrying
something maybe dragging something
behind them dead
babies drones that she's talking about
or is this that truck after she turned
it into
a toy a toy that maybe one of her kids
starts playing with
yikes
from modern family and also gives us a
bit of irony inspired by office space
i gotta get out of here i think i'm
gonna lose it uh-oh
sounds like somebody's got a case of the
mundus
but really the biggest new stuff of this
trailer comes in the very final seconds
[Music]
my my nipples just use this
magic to levitate facility
it looks like rows and rows of office
drawers but at impractical to reach
heights it almost looks like sound
proofing panels
and then a glass panel walkway with what
looks like office blinds behind her
so where is this it does kind of seem
like a sword
sort of facility yeah in their camp
outside west view would be this
elaborate i'm thinking this could be
wanda's mind palace a mental database
or library there have been uh
libraries it could be a manifestation of
one design memories
interesting it's kind of like bruce
almighty
i can see that sure you think about it
she definitely has compartmentalized
emotionally at least
or we could be seeing a flashback to
wanda's time at sokovia when she was
working with hydra
something we know will be important on
this show maybe these panels are part of
a kind of danger room
training grid then vision and light of
some kind of superpower conflict in the
west view neighborhood and the distance
behind vision appears to be a car
on fire i am now wondering if this whole
west view anomaly is the aftermath of
some
other avengers level crisis that wanda
initially went to try to help
but in order to contain it she had to
create this kind of hex
to resurrect vision which ended up with
all of them trapped inside it that
initial crisis could have been caused by
jimmy woo's
missing witness as a way to work
interesting and then this red tinted
shockwave turns a 50s black and white
city block into a modern technicolor one
i actually think this particular shot
could be in reverse
a blue car on a normal street being
warped into the
50s significant reality wanda envisioned
started this series in
then a crazy shot of vision outside the
static wall
look very closely at this this case is
still dragging him back in
no capes but look closely at bishop's
forehead looks like there's a bit of a
divot where that mine stone was yanked
out
so yeah vision oh he's going into dead
vision
creepy because he's corpses he could be
falling apart second by second with
chunks of him being dragged back in the
west
oh yeah this could be like recreating
the moment when he did die in infinity
war right there like
it's happening oh what a potential for
body horror too
and i also do think the black and white
thing going reverse makes sense i feel
like this is going to be that episode
when the first teaser came out when
they're in the living room and then
there's like a mixture of black and
white in color and it looks like she's
breaking dimensions i think it's going
to be this episode we see that the
teaser doesn't have that moment here but
i remember
that image never left my mind it's like
he is screaming
maybe for help from those sword agents
like maybe wanda is keeping him from
leaving
a sort of reversal the way he tried to
keep her in the avengers compound in the
civil war
i mean vision is aware that he is dead
he might prefer
death over this creepy false afterlife
and then in the final shot
face each other in a kind of tense
looking standoff her float off
trouble in paradise i do think one
division is gonna become
wanda versus vision but check it out a
little dog house with the name sparky
sparky is the name of vision synthesis
from the tom king vision series
one of the many comic series inspiring
this show actually i think this series
seems to be pulling from pretty much
every major scarlet witch and vision
comic title it's hard to say
whether any one of them is a bigger
influence on the story than any other
one of them
oh by the way i am wearing our i wanted
to just really quickly say
i think this moment actually might be
played for laughs i'm really under the
impression that this moment will be
something that is like they're having a
hard time being parents
they get into some type of conflict with
each other and then it's a fun way of
foreshadowing what's gonna break our
hearts with this guy's handoff later
i feel like isolated this feels like oh
this could be a serious scene yeah but
i'm i'm guessing i'm just gonna throw my
hat in the ring that it's a joke
i still do think though that it will
eventually become wanda versus vision
just learn that out there but i think
vision will help
be a sacrificial hero in the end oh by
the way i am wearing our latest
obsession shirts an
unusual couple limited supplies still
available at our merch store near
rockstarsmerch.com
you can follow me on instagram at eavos
follow me rockstars subscribe to
rockstars
breakdowns of all your one division what
the [ __ ] thanks for watching
awesome all right great stuff man great
stuff i can't wait for this week's
episode
new rock stars you guys are always
killing it all the time we're covering
new rock stars videos has been my
favorite to cover
actually subscribe to them hit that like
button keep a lookout for our one
division reaction this week last but not
least
gotta shout out my buddy eric horseman i
don't even know where to begin man this
past month
you've sent over olivia and i some
incredible engagement gifts and it just
the packages just
did not stop coming in we love every
single
one of them they are absolutely
incredible you have
just really touched our hearts so much
so that you're invited
to our honeymoon that's right eric
horseman you're coming to the honeymoon
you're gonna be in the corner
you're gonna be touching yourself right
there and
we're just gonna be looking at you the
whole time your
lucky cat you oh yeah you're a voyer you
like to be voyered on
but in all sincerity can't wait for you
to
touch yourself in front of us